[Music]
all right joining us with reaction to
the predictable left-wing well response
to the ongoing Supreme Court opening
here's the host of see our TVs Levin TV
the host of the number one show Sunday
night's 10 p.m.
it's called life liberty and Levin I
call them the great one alright before
we get into it we do have a big
announcement
do you want to say it or shall I mr.
great one sir I'll say it I'm pregnant
no actually to the Supreme Court just
self-identified well you know you are my
guest on life liberty and Levin has
switch roles where I interview for an
hour by the way that role reversal thing
is a little weird for me we already it's
I think it's a great show thank you for
having me by the way all right mark
Liberty you're probably best known for
your massive runaway bestseller and all
your books have been number one
bestsellers but liberty and tyranny but
I remember you wrote a book called men
and black and long before anybody else
you talked about this what the left can
accomplish in an election what they
can't accomplish ever legislatively they
want to ignore separation of powers
co-equal branches they'll cite foreign
law and they literally want things
legislated from the bench
you have been way ahead of the curve but
this president wants to choose an
originalist I want you to go through
their reaction to this opening now what
it means for the country first of all I
want Americans to understand that the
progressive ideology which you hear on
the left is incompatible with
constitutionalism and so they've turned
the supreme court in for them into a
Politburo into a all-powerful
centralized political operation where
they want to control a majority of the
seats you notice they don't talk about
upholding the Constitution as written
you notice they don't talk about this
article this provision this section this
clause of the Constitution when you hear
them yep a way on the other networks
they're talking about abortion on demand
same-sex marriage Obamacare open borders
they give you the same
swinging agenda as if they're running
for president or running for the Senate
that they want in a judicial nominee
that's not how it works
sure we don't want it conservative we
don't want too liberal we want a
constitutionalist a constitutionalist is
somebody who has sworn to uphold the
Constitution looks at the Constitution
looks at the words takes them in context
tries to figure out what the original
intent was and applies it and the
parties before the Supreme Court have a
right to expect that that's what the
justices will do what the Democrats are
telling the President of the United
States is if you don't nominate Ruth
Bader Ginsburg in one form or another
we're going to oppose whomever you
nominate so the Republicans are going to
have to steamroll the Democrats and
that's okay the Democrats have
politicized this process where they
don't even make any sense they used to
support filibustering it now they oppose
filibustering it they used to oppose a
nomination with one year left in the
presidency now they support it or they
don't support it now they oppose it when
it's midterm elections in other words
forget about Schumer forget about the
Democrats forget about their agenda and
let us uphold the Constitution with our
nomination and I think this president
more than most understands that he ran
for office he had his list he was
extremely transparent Hillary Clinton
didn't have a list because the nation
collectively would have puked quite
frankly but this President had his list
he has tremendous candidates on this
list and he said I'm gonna choose from
this list so the left has have every
opportunity to dig up whatever they can
on these these various candidates and
the president's sticking to the list and
this is very very important the Supreme
Court is not supposed to be more
powerful than the other two branches of
government it's supposed to be
independent from them justices are
appointed for life because they're not
to be political it's gotten way out of
whack and under the left it'll be more
out of whack here's the attitude of the
progressives who really used to attack
the Constitution you know as written by
a bunch of white men who own slaves now
they pretend to support it here's the
position of the left basically they want
to enshrine their ideology into the
Constitution when they say you have to
support precedent they don't really
believe that drew a Dred Scott uphold
slavery that was president Plessy vs.
Ferguson segregation that was precedent
Korematsu the internment of
japanese-americans that was president do
they support that precedent no what they
mean is the most radical decisions of
the Supreme Court that's what they want
to compel that's what they believe in
not the Constitution but the leftist
direction that leftist courts have taken
the Constitution I don't even know what
you you wrote men in black I assume that
it's out in print in thousand five I
think and I just look one of the reasons
we became friends and I think we go into
this a little bit I don't remember the
whole discussion but mark we became
friends because of issues and I'm gonna
tell a little bit of the story is with
all due respect to you I have to twist
your arm to do fill in for me on radio
twist your arm to do a weekend show
twist your arm to do it six to eight and
six to nine thence indicate and to be
honest it's been years I've been
twisting your arm to come on this TV
show and now you hear now you flipped it
and now I have to do your show but the
thing is that brought us together is all
right Servat ISM no I agree but I want
your viewers to know something because
we just did this interview I want the
viewers to know more about you than when
you're on TV and that's that's what
we're doing in this interview you've got
a wonderful background you've got a
great sense of humor you're one of the
most decent human beings I know it's the
attack from the left hold on now you
gave me 20 bucks I got to finish your
attack from the left and I want the
people to know really the real Sean
Hannity and that's what's gonna happen
by the way I did something that a lot of
politicians and liberals do mark would
try to get me to talk about me and I
kept talking about issues and finally is
that now stop it talk about you mark you
your love of this constitution has been
your life study I mean this I absorb
this because this is important I swear
if we don't get this right we're going
to lose this country we talk about rule
of law equal application of our laws our
constitutional form of government
foundation of all our laws and you have
been an intellectual heavyweight on all
of this let me just say one thing
last thing yeah on the son of a meeting
where well the progressives don't own
the Supreme Court they don't own seats
on the Supreme Court when they talk
about the Supreme Court's going to move
hard to the right it doesn't move hard
to the right you either believe in the
Constitution or you don't we define
everything through the left we see
everything through the left stop we want
candidates who are going to uphold the
Constitution and on drive their
political agenda by the way the
Constitution yes like Mike Lee I would
support if the president's watching Mike
Lee is your best choice that's my humble
opinion I think he would be absent on
the outside Mike Lee would be an
outstanding justice and he's brilliant I
think they would be a great choice mark
life liberty live in every Sunday night
the number one show on cable attend East
at 10:00 Eastern on Sundays and I'm
unfortunately the guest and he beats me
up this Sunday and I hope you'll watch